one of the loudest complaints that we've
heard from Donald Trump since the start
of the impeachment inquiry and it's a
complaint that his supporters have
started parroting as well is Trump's not
getting any due process in this
impeachment inquiry Donald Trump has now
chosen to at least initially waive the
due process that he has been given
because once again their complaints
aren't based in fact they are merely
whatever they can come up with at the
time to try to claim that they are the
victims they are the martyrs they are
the people that are being treated
unfairly now at the start before the
impeachment inquiry was even formalized
by Democrats Donald Trump said I've got
no due process here people around him
love the talking point they started
repeating at ad nauseam and adults had
to explain to Trump and to his followers
will hold on a second Donald Democrats
are just deciding whether to do an
impeachment inquiry due process isn't an
issue here when Democrats formalizing
inquiry which they eventually did they
voted on it they outlined the limits of
the inquiry and they also outlined the
due process that Donald Trump would get
Donald Trump now gets to have that due
process if he wants it tomorrow we have
impeachment inquiry hearings starting in
the House Judiciary Committee we will be
streaming the entire hearing live on our
YouTube channel
and Donald Trump is waving due process
by choosing not to participate in
choosing not to have any of his
attorneys participate White House lawyer
Pat chip Aloni has told the House
Judiciary Committee Trump isn't going to
participate no lawyers for Trump are
going to participate in the first
impeachment hearing of the week
scheduled for tomorrow now I want to be
really clear about something they
meaning trumpets will say you know Trump
still isn't getting due process because
the participation that he's being
offered even if he did it would be
totally skewed and biased because
Democrats control the committee well
hold on a second
we have two parties in the United States
that flip back and forth between
controlling the house and the Senate and
the idea that
the other party is in power you were
denied due process by default because
they don't agree with your politics is
number one laughable but more
importantly that doesn't take into
account what due process is Donald Trump
got the due process he wanted due
process is the normal systems notify you
and allow you to have a say and to
participate Trump was notified and given
an opportunity to be heard he is opting
not to he got due process period he
received and for now they may choose to
participate later for now is waving due
process the president is having to be
treated like a little kid and incredibly
there are people who praise the
president simply for not going out of
his way to unfairly attack others that's
how the discourse has been debased where
when Trump can avoid insulting someone
he is praised for acting like an adult
it was never about due process just like
it's never actually about any of the
things that they say it's about these
are simply ways that they figure out to
either try to attack someone else or to
play themselves as the victims and the
reaction is always either outrage
demanding an uproar and then when
they're asked to follow through they
decline like they're doing here now they
are again shifting to the entire process
is unconstitutional to begin with why
well the you might say it's a process
outlined in the Constitution how could
it be an unconstitutional process well
the latest complaint is it's supposed to
happen in the house judiciary not in the
house Intel committee where they held
hearings two weeks ago well tomorrow the
hearings start in the house judiciary so
what's the problem now oh no it's still
unconstitutional Trump is still being
denied due process they don't want
solutions they don't care about legality
they just want to complain they just
want to be martyrs they just want
victimhood this really is their strength
just to complain and talk about how
everything is so unfair to them I'm sort
of reminded of a guy pretending to be
tough
while yelling hold me back to his
friends except his friends aren't really
holding him back he's holding his
friends arms to make it look as though
he's being held back that is a
representation visually of what the
entire Trump administration has been
around these hearings it's pathetic and
we know the real reason why it wouldn't
be good for Donald Trump to participate
he would immediately self-incriminate as
we've said before Trump saying I guess
it was either early last week maybe the
week before time is really flying where
Donald Trump said he would be interested
in testifying in the impeachment inquiry
hearings he outright his lawyers would
never let him do it much the same way
that they kept him away from Robert
Muller we will have the full live
impeachment hearings starting tomorrow
morning I believe at 9:30 a.m. Eastern
we will start the hearings starting a
half hour later at youtube.com slash the
David Pakman show
I hope you will join us I think that
these will be very interesting hearings
and also important when it comes to
starting to hear from folks in the Trump
administration at least to some degree
and I look forward to it I hope you'll
join me and of course I'm sure Donald
Trump will be actively tweeting about
how everything is just so unfair now
he's the victim throughout the entire
process we'll pick that up tomorrow one
of today's sponsors is a game called
dump Trump which you can play for free
on desktop as well as iOS and Android
when you go to david pakman.com slash
trump game that's where you'll also find
the hilarious merch that they offer
which you can get for 10% off when you
use the code Pakman at checkout dump
Trump is a game where a nefarious man
named Ronald dump is trying to kidnap
your cat it's wacky but it's hilarious
and the point of the game is to find
creative ways of keeping Ronald dumped
from grabbing your cat you understand
what I'm saying right it's an
action-packed collection of 45 different
minigames nearly all of them have some
political theme related to the current
administration every minigame the only
way to win is to stop the orange
antagonist the game itself is a ton of
fun but maybe the best part about it is
that when you first open the game you
get to choose which 2020 Democratic
primary can
it you want your proceeds to go to and
every time you play the game a portion
of the revenue that comes from in-game
ads and any in-app purchases will go to
the 2020 Democratic candidate of your
choice and as part of this promotion
they're doing with us they'll be giving
an additional 25% to your favorite
candidate maybe you support Bernie or
Warren or Andrew yang regardless of who
you're pulling for in the Democratic
primary
you can send small donations to your
favorite candidate just by playing this
game and it is a game I think you'll
have a lot of fun with it's called dump
Trump you can play it for free on
desktop or on your phone when you go to
david pakman.com slash trump game and
when you go there you can also save 10%
on dump Trump merchandise when you use
the coupon code Pakman at checkout